So speaking of my mother I want to show
you these beautiful beautiful things
that my aunt just said to me I had no
idea they existed these are paintings
that my mother did before she died we
are selling them
and we're selling them because I don't
really want them they don't fit the
color scheme in my homes no they don't
fit the color scheme in my homes my aunt
said you want them I said no I'm working
with designers and we can't fit this in
we can't fit it in I've spoken to these
people and I mean I have an art dealer I
should call
no I have I don't think she'll answer
let me ask you a question this is crazy
my mother was kind of like an artist she
painted two things you know she was
schizophrenic and I know I mean not to
be crass about it but I know some of the
art World likes stuff like that yeah no
definitely you know what I mean yeah
send it to me I'd love to see you yes
all right thank you so much I appreciate
it
right thank you
are we not living in the folks are we
not living in a great world folks are we
not living in a great world